hello there I'm John Oliver host of last
week tonight we are off the air this
week because to boost ratings on HBO
I plan to murder and dismember a friend
of mine apparently that's how it works
now anyway anyway think this season this
season I'll do it I'll do it I'll do it
what are you encouraging anyway this
season we've covered the tobacco
industry voting rights in the American
territories and our country's
infrastructure but right now I'd like to
talk about a serious problem April
Fool's Day April Fool's Day is to comedy
as st. Patrick's Day is to Irish culture
that is to say it is a mockery of the
very concept that usually ends in a
fistfight but you may not know that
April Fool's Day was actually invented
by FDR in 1934 as a way to raise
national morale during the Great
Depression April Fool that's not true at
all I made it up you trusted me and I
betrayed that trust I've betrayed you
is it betrayal fun that felt bad didn't
it well now I want you to sit in that
terrible feeling for a moment because he
may have been laughing on the outside
but on the inside admit it you were sad
well first of all welcome to my brave
second of all I'm sorry I did that to
you that was a prank and pranks are
terrible anyone who claims to be excited
for April Fool's Day is probably a
sociopath because what they're really
saying is I cannot wait to hurt the
people close to me I can't wait and and
if you want to break your family's
hearts don't play a mean trick on them
just ask them for money for another
improv class do it done and you can do
that any time of year and you will
shatter them now not to mention we don't
need a special holiday to disappoint our
loved ones we do that enough on every
other holiday by accident okay Nana when
are you gonna yell Christmas fools and
give me my real present
this sweater is an abomination but that
being said I want to help you have the
best April Fool's Day ever so close
close your eyes right now do it close
them and visualize the greatest
practical joke you can possibly imagine
and now never do that thing you thought
of
ever don't even tell anyone you thought
of it you're a monster
in fact
in fact let's do this properly everyone
watching this please raise your right
hand and take the last week tonight no
prank pledge repeat after me
I solemnly swear that on this April
Fool's Day I will not post a fake
engagement photo on Facebook like some
kind of normal I prepare a to
celebrity death hoax because that makes
people sad in fact I will not play any
practical jokes and if I see someone
planning a prank I will say to them hey
you're being a dick right now stop being
a dick
we'll go back we'll go back we'll go
back say to them hey you're being a dick
right now stop being a dick
stop being a dick seriously stop being a
dick thank you very much for taking the
last week tonight no prank pledge
hopefully with your support we can
restore the original meaning of April
the first the day we traditionally look
at our calendars and think oh I
really have to do my taxes oh
luckily tonight we'll be back next
Sunday with a volume
you